[Music]
this is the 36-inch reflector telescope
it's used to study the stars
okay wait i have a question that is on
my mind and
i can't stop thinking about it which is
is it possible to take a picture of
another galaxy
like can someone do that who's not nasa
like from your backyard can you point
your camera at the sky
and actually capture another galaxy that
would be crazy
this was a moment for me i've only had a
few moments like this in my life
where i ask what feels like a simple
innocent question
but it's actually not a simple question
it's a question that ends up being like
a spark
lit into a dry field of brush
this question sat with me for a few
weeks
and then one day i finally broke down
and just googled it
the main tool
the answer is yes standing in your
backyard even if you live next to a
light polluted city you can photograph a
galaxy like a different galaxy outside
of our own
i promised myself that i would do
whatever it took
to photograph another galaxy
let's make one thing clear up front
which is that i am not an astronomer
before this i'd never looked through a
telescope i couldn't name any stars or
point out any constellations
so what you're about to see is a long
frustrating journey
of me trying to learn something that is
unbelievably technical and precise
it's a story of complicated gear that
seems impossible to learn
complicated software it's the story of a
laptop that arrived at my door one day
and it's the story of hitting rock
bottom and wanting to give up
i'm going to bed i'm going to bed i'm
going to
bed so this is the story of my quest
to photograph a galaxy
[Music]
after a bunch of research i set my
sights on a galaxy called messier 101 or
m101 and even though this isn't the
brightest galaxy in the sky
it seemed like a good choice because
it's always above the horizon
and it's one that i could try to
photograph from the back patio of my
studio
this galaxy is 21 million light years
away
meaning the light we're seeing now has
been traveling for 21 million years
and the galaxy is somewhere around the
handle of the big dipper
you can't actually see it with your eye
but presumably
it's there this is the little patch of
sky that i would begin
looking at night after night hoping that
behind the light pollution
and all of this darkness that there was
light
that had been traveling for millions of
years that i could connect with
and capture on my camera but let's not
get ahead of ourselves
there was still a lot of work to do
[Music]
i have a feeling i'm getting in way over
my head
now i've taught myself a lot of
technical skills all my animation
and filmmaking skills i learned just by
watching tutorials on the internet
there's one thing i've learned about
this
self-teaching process and it looks like
this
if you want to learn something new like
a language a piece of software a
technical skill
you inevitably have your eye on the
prize what you want to do with that
skill
you see your goal and you start walking
towards it but you'll quickly realize
that this journey is not as
straightforward as you thought
you start to descend you get deeper and
deeper
into new unfamiliar information lots of
weird new concepts that seemingly have
nothing to do with your end goal
you're soon so deep in this that you
feel like you're not getting anywhere
you feel further from your goal than you
were when you started
like it's totally out of sight but the
secret here that you learn after you do
this process a few times
is that eventually you hit rock bottom
of this
mind-numbing chaotic intake of
information
and after you hit rock bottom you start
going up you're moving towards your goal
again
concepts that used to just feel like
mind-numbing chaos start to make sense
and you realize that you're moving
towards your goal and eventually you
emerge from this abyss
and you reach your goal but it was only
through that descent
and that rise that you were able to do
this
this is the process for learning
difficult things
from calculus to a new language the
cruelest part about this whole abyss of
learning
is that the whole thing is shrouded in
fog meaning
when you are descending down into this
you don't know where the bottom is you
don't know if the bottom is here
or if it's all the way down here this is
a scary
uncertain frustrating reality and it's
why most people
quit when they're trying to learn a new
skill like this the only thing you can
do
is just keep going
[Music]
alexa make the office lights
red
there we go
[Music]
i watched a few tutorials on how to set
this stuff up and it's
feeling incredibly complicated
so after that first night of setting up
the camera
and like dramatically struggling to like
get it all working
and all that stuff i thought i was like
deep in this learning abyss
and i have no idea what i'm doing i
thought i was like here
i had absorbed all this info i'd done
all the research on what gear i needed
to buy
and i set it all up i read the
instruction manual i was like man i am
so deep in this astrophotography thing
big lens i feel like it's speaking my
language just like
a few days away from photographing a
galaxy
no no no no no no i was not
even close i was actually here
the fog was very thick and i had no idea
and so over the next couple of weeks i
began to realize
what was actually happening here before
you can even take
pictures of the night sky the first
thing you have to do is take this
mount and you have to align it to the
night sky you point it at different
stars you align it to the north star you
do all this stuff to basically tell the
mount where it is
in the world and where the night sky is
and then it starts to track the night
sky
as the earth spins it's really cool but
it's
kind of complicated to get it right i'm
deep in this
dark sky way out at my cabin everything
should be perfect
and i can't even align my telescope and
it's super important because if your
telescope isn't aligned it's not going
to be able to point in the right patch
of sky to photograph a galaxy
well now i've got a giant full moon to
keep me company
but the reality is i just spent 30
minutes trying to locate the northern
star with my
polar alignment scope thing so i've got
much bigger problems than a full moon
i had predicted that it would take me
one or maybe two days to get this
alignment right instead after about a
month
i finally started to have success
aligning my telescope mount
moment of truth i think the telescope is
now
totally lined and if it points at the
moon that means i did it right
here we go enter it's going
oh man oh
man it's pointing at them it's pointing
at the moon
i finally got my telescope mount aligned
to the night sky and i thought okay the
hard part's over
i've done it i've aligned the telescope
now i just need to take my picture
and it turns out i was totally right in
fact i was already on my way up from the
abyss
i just had to press a couple of buttons
and suddenly i was getting amazing shots
of far away galaxies every night
no that is definitely not what happened
in fact the reality was that i had
barely inched down
to where i was before there was still a
lot
more to go luckily i had stumbled upon
an instagram account
with some amazing shots of the night sky
i dm'd andrew who runs the account and
asked for some help
andrew kept talking about stacking
stacking your images
stick the images i need to
take multiple pictures of the same patch
of sky so i can
layer them together you're not just
taking one picture of a galaxy
you're taking hundreds of pictures of
that same patch of sky
and you integrate them together you
stack them together
which will get rid of a lot of the weird
noise and stuff and it will allow you to
see
the galaxy stacking
so i did what andrew and the internet
tutorials told me to do
i took hundreds of shots while my
telescope mount would track this little
patch of sky where i hoped the galaxy
was
but then came the slow part spending
hours
loading these huge image files onto my
computer
and waiting what seemed like forever for
the computer to process
and calibrate and stack all of these
images into one final image
this took forever and often the final
result
wasn't very encouraging this is very
disappointing
it's one in the morning and i'm looking
at basically a black
frame with a few little dots that are
the stars
and the software gave me this nothing
it looks like nothing it looks like a
bunch of
white dots on a black background
i'm really excited about this new hobby
of mine
i don't know man i'm going to bed i'm
going to bed
i'm going to bed here is the moment that
i was ready to
throw in the towel to give up i had
invested a lot of time
and money into this goal and i felt like
i was
nowhere closer to photographing and
seeing m101
than when i started after hours of these
brain numbing tutorials
and fiddling with these tools and trying
night after night all i had to show for
it was
this i started to question if the
telescope was even pointing in the right
bit of sky to capture m101
i was ready to give up
it's months later
and i've been trying a million things
i'm
budding up against a really really
complicated reality which is
i'm trying to photograph a galaxy
outside of my own millions of light
years away from me
of course that's going to be hard the
idea of photographing a galaxy feels
so distant for me like it feels so
[Music]
far away i couldn't see it then but i
see now that that night
i was at rock bottom it was at the
bottom of this abyss
my quest to photograph a galaxy had
turned into a mess
of sleepless nights fiddling with
complicated equipment and
hours waiting for my computer to process
hundreds of images
it seemed like i really hadn't learned
anything but in fact i had
i had made it through the most
excruciating part the descent
into chaotic novel abstract information
and now it was time to go up
i really wanted a rocky style montage
and i didn't get that in real life but
the best i can do
is give you that rocky montage so here
it goes
a few things happen next first i
committed to
devouring tutorials daily there's a
pretty active
niche community of astrophotographers on
the internet
many of whom take it upon themselves to
make extensive tutorials
part one part two and part three i had
watched a lot of these tutorials before
but they didn't actually make sense the
first time around
but now months later i could watch them
and they actually started to sink in
luckily it was at this time that i got
reached out to
by nvidia who makes like graphics cards
and hardware for computers
they wanted to send me an hp laptop that
was packed with a really nice graphics
card
this would make my workflow a lot easier
because now i would have a computer with
a graphics card that actually
talked to my software and was optimized
for really
fast editing and fast processing
especially in photoshop and lightroom
this would make the whole process a lot
quicker and what this meant as well is
that i could use this laptop which was a
pc
to control a dedicated astro camera so i
could do it all for my computer
this new machine empowered me and
completely changed the game
i'm on my way up this is amazing
i am getting there
[Music]
but it didn't photograph the galaxy for
me i still had a lot of work to do
over the next couple of months this was
my life i started sleeping on the patio
so that i could image throughout the
night
and then one night i was at my computer
fishing around in this sea of grainy
pixels
and i saw something holy crap
okay this is my really shitty image from
last night but if you zoom
in you actually start to see
a literal galaxy that is insane
yeah this is this is hundreds of images
together
[Music]
it's paying off this looked like my
galaxy
like m101 i immediately texted my
astrophotography
sensei andrew but as i said in the text
there's still a lot of work to do
and then one day it happened
i made it to the top i was on the other
side of this abyss
i stacked 400 images from a night of
shooting
i brought it into my new computer i
stacked it up
integrated it processed it did all of
these things that i had now done
hundreds of times
and in that moment i answered my
question from months earlier from your
backyard
can you point your camera at the sky and
actually capture another galaxy
yes me from the past you can photograph
another galaxy standing on the back
patio of your studio
if you just point your telescope at the
right patch of sky
for the right amount of time you will be
able to capture light that has been
traveling for
21 million years to meet you and you can
record that
as an image and that image looks like
this
this is m101 or the pinwheel galaxy
21 million light years from earth it's
one of the most beautiful things
i've ever seen mainly because i worked
so hard to capture this bit of light
that was really hard very discouraging
at times
but throughout all of it there were
really special moments i got to spend
countless nights outside looking up
contemplating the distances in space
something my brain
can't even begin to digest and all of
this in order to capture
a little bit of light from 21 million
years ago that has been
traveling towards earth all that time
and i got to record that little teaspoon
of light
this process gave me a new perspective
one i won't easily forget it taught me
that
if you want to learn something new all
that stands between you and that goal
is a descent and a rise through this
abyss another takeaway from this process
was the importance of
having good tools for your goal as i
told you in this story
this moment actually happened where i
was struggling i was spending so much
time on these image stacks
and i then got reached out to by nvidia
and hp who wanted to send me this laptop
that promised
way better performance and indeed it
delivered
suddenly my image stacking workflow
which would take me like an hour
suddenly was like a 15 minute thing more
importantly when i would open up these
images that are like
400 megabyte tiff files you know really
really heavy i'd open them up in
photoshop
no more lagging i was able to like zoom
in and actually zoom around
this image and edit it and there was no
like flashy lagging issues that i was
getting with my old laptop
the display was like butter smooth i
could zoom in i could change levels and
curves and all this stuff and like it
would just
update on the display it was just a
pleasure to work on and
made it way less discouraging for me to
practice my
post-processing this is all made
possible because nvidia the graphics
card maker
has found a way to get the graphics card
to talk to the software
in a way that is optimized for
performance
so now when i'm rendering stuff in
premiere it's
way faster like 30 minute renders
suddenly turn into like 12-minute
renders
if i'm trying to render proxies for you
know a time lapse which is like hundreds
and hundreds of images
that's now going at double or triple the
speed
i'm incredibly grateful for that because
it helped kick-start my second wind to
help me actually get serious about
completing this goal
again this wasn't some like fabricated
planned moment this actually happened
in the course of my trying to complete
this goal so there's a link in my
description if you want to check out
this laptop
or learn more about nvidia and their
studio drivers and how that works to
make your workflow quicker
go check out that link and thank you to
nvidia and hp
for supporting this video and supporting
my goal to photographic galaxy for
sending me this laptop
and for supporting this channel last
thing i'll say is if anyone wants a
high-res version of this galaxy image
that i shot i'm going to be giving it
out to anyone who is a patron
on patreon so go check out my patreon if
you want a high-res version or anything
else that's on patreon
thank you all for watching
[Music]